[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome this is
Lord sovereign here coming to you live
from play NYC we're here for Lords of
gaming dotnet in the iron Lords podcast
I'm with Jonah from well whale food
games Jonah is well food games and we're
here to talk about kungfu kickball i saw
this game from across the room I said I
have to go see what kung-fu kickball is
so Jonah tell us a little bit about you
sure so kungfu kickball is a team-based
fighting sports game or the best ball
kicker wins got a punch kick and
headbutt your way across the field to
smash the ball into the opponent's Bell
and rack up points oh my god so it's
it's so it's rocket League would you
just head-butting and craziness of smash
brothers okay so I see I'm looking at
the so are you selecting different
arenas here different arenas okay three
different characters okay they got the
monk the ninja and the old master okay
it looks like they both chose the monk
for this one
so tell me what was the inspiration for
the game like where did you you know cuz
I have getting a lot of like oh was it
with kung-fu soccers yeah I mean there's
a movie called Shaolin Soccer which is
also a big inspiration but also just I
want something to bring people together
you know something to play with friends
and stuff those would be fun to show at
conventions and I kind of mixed my two
two games that I really liked
rocket Lee against brother those were
the biggest break yeah I'm definitely
getting that vibe from both so tell me
um in terms of like in terms of like
different modes besides the main versus
mode is there something else like it
different types of yeah I don't know
different ways to score things like it
so it's mainly the main versus mode is
what I concentrate on which is like
three minute match you can do one be 1
or 2 v 2 I will have online play there
will be like in arcade mode where you
can fight the AI but really gonna
concentrate on like fighting other
people so in terms of in terms of moves
besides the base moves that they have
other like super moves and stuff like
there are some so I tried to keep all
the moves kind of easy to pull off and I
like Smash Brothers
okay so you got smash attacks you can do
directional attacks you know up attack
kicks the ball in the air but then you
also have a charge boob so you'll hold
down attack you can do a charged up
attack and they have different ones of
that we'll see these guys figure it out
got guys do Street do Street Fighter
moves do move Yusei just figure out got
some special moves so we could so I see
I see that you had like the avatars
right the blue and the red
who was it at any point did you think
about like creating full-on characters
for the game so that is something that
you considering yeah
you know these will always be an option
so these are my own artwork the
characters there but I'm thinking of
getting an artist to actually you know
maybe fill in the characters yeah
absolutely cuz the game has so much
personality already you can already see
how you can hear if you guys can hear
how much fun pipe and kognito I'm having
and I guess this is the point right to
be able to couch co-op and of course
online so tell me is the game now when
is it coming out so goal is bringing out
early 2020 okay
platforms so definitely PC and I'm not
allowed to say which consoles it's
coming out for it without a plural
though that plural baby well Jonah thank
you so much for your time the game looks
absolutely amazing I'm gonna sit down
and play in a few minutes because this
is nuts and I this reminds me we as a
podcast we've been friends for many
years and we used to go to comedy
needles house every Saturday nights I'd
play Tekken WWE wrestling games things
like that and this is the type of game
that will keep you there for hours on
end just joking going back and forth
with different so I think you've created
something amazing here I wish you all
the best this this looks absolutely
great thank you so much you know that's
definitely the gold like bring back that
kind of friends getting together playing
each other's houses that's what I wanted
so definitely plug the game tell us
where people can find more information
about it
so Punk foo kickball calm they can get
the info you can also join our discord
their Twitter it is at whale food games
and I think Facebook is whale food or
something you heard it there first iron
Lords podcast kungfu kickball check it
out
looks awesome thanks guys
[Music]
you